dr libre c'est un géant français du
numérique
l'entreprise à d'ailleurs gagné
l'insigne honneur d'entrer dans le
cercle très fermé des licornes française
cette petite quinzaine de start up
hexagonale valorisées hors marché à plus
d'un milliard d'euros comme deezer ovh
cloud ou bla bla car créé en 2013 d'octo
liban était déjà reconnu comme un
champion du secteur avant 2020 mais il
est clair qu'une partie de son récent
est indéniable succès doit beaucoup à la
crise sanitaire
selon nos confrères du monde 50 millions
de personnes ils sont désormais inscrits
dont 5 millions en allemagne soit 10
millions de plus en un an
dr libre gère jusqu'à 90% de l'accès aux
centres de vaccination avec un record le
11 mai dernier de près de 500000 rendez
vous et encore seulement pour les
premières injections pour rappel ce
jour-là environ 650 mille français
s'étaient fait vacciner environ vingt
mille médecins seraient actuellement
abonnés à la plateforme et au 1er avril
2020 le nombre total de téléconsultation
réalisé sur le site avaient été
multipliés par cent et ce en un mois
seulement d'octo libre s'est ainsi
hissée au troisième rang mondial des
services de téléconsultation derrière
l'américain terra d'oc et le chinois
oui doctor alors devant ce palmarès
certains se sont tout de même inquiété
car qui dit millions d'utilisateurs 10
millions de données personnelles et ici
il s'agit également de données de santé
encore plus sensible des données dont la
sécurité et la confidentialité ne serait
pas à toute épreuve
contrairement à ce qu'affirme d'octo
libre premièrement et bien il existe
déjà les risques habituels liés au
numérique c'est-à-dire le vol pur et
simple de données personnelles par des
hackers qui exploiterait une faille de
sécurité et dr libre à cet égard
n'échappe pas à la règle puisque la
plateforme a été victime d'un vol de
données
le 21 juillet 2020 les pirates ont ainsi
eu le temps d'accéder aux informations
relatives à plus de 6000 rendez vous
notamment les nom prénoms sexe téléphone
et adresse mail des patients et si le
motif du rendez-vous prix n'a lui pas pu
être lues la spécialité du praticien à
elle bien été consultés ensuite il y à
la question très technique
du stockage et du chiffrement des
données dr yb ne stocke pas soi même les
données de ses utilisateurs mais en
laisse le soin à un acteur bien connu
dans le domaine à w est ce la solution
cloud de l'américain amazon le
chiffrement a été confiée quant à lui au
français atos un leader européen de la
cybersécurité en théorie donc pas de
problème sauf que de récentes enquêtes
ont remis en cause la confidentialité de
ces données
c'est le cas de france inter qui a
constaté que certaines données étaient
consultables en clair donc non chiffrée
des conclusions similaires ont été
formulées par l'association interop qui
milite pour l'utilisation de logiciels
de santé libre et open source ou
rapportés par le site spécialisé nixines
pacte sans compter que la
confidentialité de toutes ces données
personnelles est également menacé cette
fois-ci par la législation américaine
les etats unis disposent en effet d'un
arsenal d'outils juridiques comme le
cloud acte l'article 702 du fise a ou
encore l'exécutive order 12330 3 qui
permettent en gros ou renseignements
américains de collecter et traiter
toutes données personnelles de tout
citoyen européen stockées sur les
serveurs de n'importe quelle entreprise
américaine ce qui est le cas des données
de dr libre hébergé en france certes
mais sur des serveurs américains
alors on peut relativiser et se dire que
jusqu'à présent les millions de données
confidentielles recueillis par d'octo
libres sont bien restés à l'abri des
regards indiscrets
le conseil d'état a d'ailleurs considéré
dans une ordonnance du 12 mars 2021 que
la plateforme offrait des garanties de
sécurité suffisantes
mais cet avis de la plus haute
juridiction administrative a depuis fait
l'objet de nombreuses critiques
l'une des solutions pourrait peut-être
venir d'un éventuel et cloud européen
sous réserve qu'ils aient fonctionné
surtout qu'ils apportent réellement aux
citoyens européens et donc français la
souveraineté numérique promu par
emmanuel macron mais qui fait toujours
cruellement défaut aujourd'hui